today's video was made possible by
masterworks more on this in a moment
[Music]
finland is a country famous for having
the highest concentration of heavy metal
bands per capita in the world nope i
didn't make this up someone on the
internet did a study with a map included
but let's focus on today's topic because
as you can imagine today we're not
talking about finland because of metal i
wish we were in recent weeks both sweden
and finland have been all over the media
for this reason
sweden and finland to formally submit
nato bids hand in hand this is a blow to
russia especially in the case of finland
in fact if you don't mind in this video
we're going to focus more on finland the
question is why is russia bothered how
important are sweden and finland to nato
at the end of the day we're talking
about two countries with small
populations sweden has just over 10
million people and finland just over 5.5
million why would it be such a tragedy
for russia if they joined nato what
problems might these two countries
encounter along the way can they really
join nato and what could russia do to
prevent it today we're going to answer
these questions but first let's take a
look at a bit of history
history repeats itself
we could say that ukraine is a case of
deja vu for finland these two countries
have so many things in common that it
seems like the same story with different
characters like ukraine finland was also
part of the russian empire in 1917 they
gained independence however in 1939
stalin decided to invade them why you
might ask what reasons did the russians
have to invade the poor finns what was
the kremlin's narrative to justify the
war against finland well pay attention
to this soviet propaganda poster
that's right it's just what it looks
like a nazi who is carrying a little dog
on a leash the little dog is an allegory
for finland in fact i don't know if you
can see the text well but it says the
fascist's dog barks exactly according to
stalin russia had to conquer finland in
order to de-nazify it this is how the
so-called winter war broke out a war
that russia hopes to win in a few weeks
the soviet union outnumbered finland on
all fronts they had more soldiers better
weapons and more money however the finns
put up resistance they knew the terrain
much better and knew how to resist the
cold much better than anyone else ever
since then finland still has whole
regiments of ski soldiers
it was in this war that legends such as
simo haiha better known as the white
death were forged he was the deadliest
sniper in history racking up 505
confirmed kills after a hundred days of
war in the most extreme conditions you
can imagine russia withdrew
many of you probably already know this
story what is often not mentioned is
that finland did not win the war at
least it was not a resounding victory
apart from the human cost and all the
war damage finland had to pay 300
million dollars to russia as reparations
to give you an idea that would be about
5.78 billion dollars in today's dollars
in addition russia got a couple of
regions in northern finland and a good
part of coralia so the question that
many of you are probably asking is was
it worth it was finland right to stand
up to russia or perhaps it would have
been better to surrender the war the
answer could not be more emphatic yes
the data speaks for itself
as of today finns enjoy a gdp per capita
of 49 thousand dollars in the republic
of korea it is less than 7 170 life
expectancy in finland it is 81 years in
russia it is 73 inequality finland is
one of the most egalitarian countries in
the world with a genie coefficient of
27.7 russia on the other hand is far
more unequal with a genie coefficient of
35.3 in other words no matter which
indicator we look at finland is among
the higher rankings and russia among the
lowest no doubt these poor coralians on
the border with finland are wondering
every day why their ancestors did not
get the border moved a little further to
the east in fact the republic of coralia
is one of the regions with the least
support for putin's party although that
matters little in russian democracy in
other words there are few examples where
a border makes such a big difference in
the lives of citizens but now the
question you all may be wondering is why
is it so important for finland and
sweden to join nato what do they bring
to the alliance is it just a symbolic
move or is there more to it well we're
now going to look at that right now but
before we continue let me talk to you
about the company that may change your
perception of investing realities
masterworks celebrities political
leaders and titans of industry now more
than ever they are putting their money
towards one thing in particular fine art
you see the s p 500 is down 17 from its
annual high and the 10-year treasury
continues to slip yes the art market has
shown resilience in fact in may 2022 the
auction houses saw record high prices
christie's sold 831 million 261
500 worth of art in just seven days and
sotheby's maclo sale achieved a record
total sale of 922 million dollars the
global head of city private bank art
advisory and finance said that the mac
low sale has showed that there was still
plenty of demand for works by museum
validated names that's because more than
just serving as decoration for mansions
fine art can be an amazing way to
protect wealth and possibly earn a
handsome return on investment so we
weren't surprised to learn that 85 of
wealth managers recommend it as part of
a portfolio according to deloitte and
with a new multi-millionaire made every
17 minutes in 2021 the demand for
high-end pieces keeps rising this means
the already limited supply of fine art
could skyrocket in value so how can we
position ourselves to take advantage of
this boom without needing millions for a
painting well with masterworks you can
get high value art into your portfolio
for a fraction of the full cost because
you're investing an amount you choose
into shares in a painting instead of
millions for the full piece we think
this is a revolutionary idea and seeing
has all the paintings they've sold so
far have returned over 30 net of fees to
members the value is just incredible of
course past performance is no guarantee
of future results if you want to check
them out click the link in the
description for priority access that
allows you to skip their waiting list
[Music]
you didn't want nato here have some nato
finland and sweden are the most
difficult countries in the world to
invade they are two examples of what we
would call total security that is the
whole society is prepared for an
invasion from the military to civilians
to give you an idea sweden has more than
65 000 wartime shelters in fact in some
swedish regions it is mandatory for
every house to have its own bunker in
helsinki the capital of finland there
are more than 5 500 bunkers in addition
both finland and sweden have
well-equipped armies that are perfectly
adapted to nato requirements
but there is something much more
important than all of that the great
contribution of finland and sweden to
nato is geography take a look at this
map
[Music]
here you can see the baltic sea finland
sweden and estonia control the entire
russian pathway to the baltic from saint
petersburg estonia is already a member
of nato if finland joins nato could
block the traffic of all russian ships
leaving saint petersburg and you will
say okay but russia still has access to
the baltic colleen ingrad but hold on a
minute because right in front of
kaliningrad is sweden which is also
about to join nato
[Music]
sweden also has this island you see here
the island of gotland until months ago
this island was demilitarized but sweden
has now sent in troops and from there it
can control this whole area of the
baltic sea russia wanted to avoid having
nato on its border now it's going to be
surrounded by nato at the only point
where they could access the atlantic if
they want to put a submarine with
nuclear warheads and service for example
it is almost impossible not to be
detected by radar remember that all nato
armies share information
[Music]
and i know what many of you are thinking
is the baltic sea really that's
important for russia technically they
also have access to the black sea the
black sea is also a tense one look at
this other map
[Music]
if you look you will see that the only
exit from the black sea to the
mediterranean sea is the bosphorous
strait which is in turkey and yes turkey
is also a nato member in other words
russia could be about to lose control of
all of its access points to the sea at
least on the western front but not only
that take a look at this third map
[Music]
this led you see on the russian side is
the kola peninsula this is estimated to
be the area with the most nuclear silos
in the world this is where russia is
likely to have almost all of its nuclear
warheads and aviation bases according to
caspian report all these military bases
are connected by a single railroad line
i'm not kidding that means that most of
russia's nuclear arsenal would be
connected by a single rail line all it
would take is one well-orchestrated
attack and all the logistics lines
feeding this nuclear arsenal would
collapse so far none of this has been a
problem for russia the only ones who
could possibly sabotage that railroad
line would be the finns but finland was
not in nato and remained neutral all
this is about to change so you can
imagine what this means for russia side
note of course this does not mean that
russia would lose all of its nuclear
bombs but it is clear that it would be
more difficult for russia to draw on its
entire nuclear arsenal in other words
finland joining nato is something russia
cannot afford to happen the question is
what can they do to prevent it right now
we're gonna see
too late to act
[Music]
how many times have you heard about nato
expansion according to russian
propaganda nato is like an oil slick
taking over new countries as we are
seeing in this case it is not nato that
is expanding it is the countries that
feel threatened by russia that are
seeking protection however joining nato
is not an automatic process from the
time a country applies for membership
until it finally enters there is a
period where it is particularly weak
think about it once sweden and finland
join nato russia would not be able to
attack them it would be an attack
against nato as a whole however until
that happens russia could launch small
attacks without nato being forced to
respond that explains threats like this
russia threatens military technical
retaliation over finland's nato bid but
what could russia do
[Music]
in principle they could launch cruise
missiles at certain strategic sites in
finland they could destroy power plants
communication towers and collapse the
whole economy without nato support
finland would not be able to respond or
maybe it would listen up
uk shrinks new security agreement with
sweden and finland that's right boris
johnson has been quicker than nato
itself before the other member countries
decide whether to accept finland and
sweden the uk has already pledged
military cooperation that means that if
moscow attacks london responds i
remember that the uk does have nuclear
weapons but not only that after the uk's
move other countries have followed suit
next came poland and then the united
states the window of opportunity for
russia has already closed
although finland and sweden are not in
nato yet they already have the support
of two nuclear powers could russia
attack with economic measures of course
the kremlin has already announced that
it is cutting off all gas supplies to
finland and that is a problem but from
the military point of view they have
fewer and fewer options and that
explains why days after threatening so
many reprisals moscow's discourse has
changed radically listen up
russian foreign affairs minister sergey
lavrov says finland sweden joining nato
makes no big difference that's right it
doesn't make a big difference and i know
what you're thinking so if russia can't
do anything it's only a matter of time
before finland joins nato right is it
possible for anything to go wrong well
we're going to take a look at that right
now
[Music]
negotiation time
[Music]
in principle nato has an open door
policy in other words finland and sweden
could join without any problems the
problem is that all member countries
have to accept it unanimously and which
countries would want to veto the entry
of sweden and finland into nato well
mainly to hungary and turkey
particularly turkey check it out
turkey's erdogan link sweden finland
nato bid to return of terrorists those
of you who subscribe to our weekly
bulletin already know about this turkey
has been fighting against the kurdish
minority for years turkey has several
kurdish organizations on its list of
terrorist groups however both sweden and
finland have given political asylum to
members of these organizations
specifically these two countries have
refused to extradite 33 individuals
according to turkey this implies
collaboration with terrorists and they
are not willing to accept the entry of
sweden and finland into nato until they
collaborate in their fight against the
kurds but we're not only talking about
kurds according to erdogan the followers
of fertilla gulen are also included in
the list of terrorist groups if you
remember fethullah gulen is one of
erdogan's political enemies and one of
the main alleged instigators of the 2016
coup
[Applause]
the question is is this really the only
reason well most probably not we've told
you several times on visualpolitik
turkey is the bad boy of nato and that
means the united states has vetoed them
from buying many weapons for example
turkey cannot buy f-35s however they
could now use their veto power to
renegotiate and so far it's paying off
check it out
turkey confirms uk lifted embargo on
defense exports so that's it you'll say
nato will go back to selling arms to
turkey as if nothing had happened in
return turkey will accept sweden and
finland issue resolved right well it's
not that simple once again turkey is
nato's problem child why well among many
other things because of its eternal
animosity towards another nato member
greece it is very likely that greece
will not be very happy if its main
antagonist once again has access to the
united states state-of-the-art military
arsenal to what extent could hungary
veto this new nato expansion will it
really be possible to resolve all these
differences
[Music]
one thing is clear except for turkey and
hungary it seems that all other members
are more than ready to accept new
members the question is how are they
going to convince hungary and turkey are
sweden and finland really going to end
up joining nato is there any way russia
could prevent it will we see a massive
propaganda campaign to try to convince
europeans that finland and sweden are
nazi dominated countries well you can
leave me your answers in the comments
and as always don't forget that here on
visualpolitik we release new videos
every week so subscribe to the channel
hit the bell icon so you don't miss any
of our updates and remember remember
that you can also support us on patreon
and you will get access to our bulletin
exclusive content and merchandising if
you like this video like it i'll see you
in the next one all the best and see you
soon
[Music]